the the water with that objection the
chair is authorized to declare recesses
of the committee at any time I'm going
to recognize myself for an opening
statement then the ranking member the
gentleman from Michigan and the
gentleman from California mr. I said and
the gentleman from Virginia mr. Scott
that we will proceed to hearing from the
Attorney General Attorney General Eric
Holder appeared before the House
Judiciary Committee last May and we
appreciate his willingness to appear
today to address many issues including
questions about his previous testimony
while I am pleased to welcome back
Attorney General Holder I am
disappointed in the department's
repeated refusal to cooperate with this
committee's oversight request this lack
of cooperation is evident and the
department's handling of inquiries
related to the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
Firearms and Explosives Operation Fast
and Furious and the death of Border
Patrol Agent Brian Terry in December
2010 and any consistent statements from
Department officials about who knew what
and when have only raised more concerns
I'm also disappointed in how the
department has responded to my oversight
request regarding justice Kagan's
involvement in health care legislation a
related litigation while she served as
United States Solicitor General despite
claims from Obama administration
officials that then Solicitor General
Kagan was walled off from discussions
regarding the president's health care
law recently released emails indicate
there may be more to the story on March
21st 2010 an email from the Deputy
Solicitor General afforded to Solicitor
General Kagan contained information
about a meeting at the White House on
the health care law and asked I think
you should go no I will regardless but
Phil this is litigation of singular
importance Solicitor General Kagan
responded by asking him for his phone
number we also know from the emails that
she personally supported the
legislations passage in a March 21st
2010 exchange with the Justice
Department colleague discussing the
health care legislation mrs. Kagan
exclaimed
I hear they have the votes Larry simply
amazing these emails reveal
inconsistencies with the
administration's claims that then
Solicitor General Kagan was walled off
from the issue to help clear up any
confusion I wrote the Justice Department
to get additional documents and conduct
staff interviews it took nearly four
months before the department sent a
one-page response that denied my request
the Department did not assert any legal
privilege over the requested information
but simply refused to comply with the
request that is not a sufficient answer
health care legislation was passed by
the Senate on December 24 2009 On
January 8 2010 Ms Kagan told the Deputy
Solicitor General that she definitely
would like the office of the Solicitor
General to be involved in preparations
to defend against challenges to the
pending health care proposals MS Kagan
found out she was being considered for a
potential Supreme Court vacancy on March
5th 2010 so the issue is how involved
was she in health care discussions
between January 8th and March 5 just as
President Nixon had an 18 and a half
minute gap does mrs. Kagan have a
two-month gap the office of the
Solicitor General is responsible for
defending the positions of the federal
government in litigation before the
Supreme Court so it was the duty of then
Solicitor General Kagan to participate
in meetings and discussions regarding
the legal defense strategy for the
president's health care proposal it
would have been a surprising departure
from her responsibilities for Solicitor
General Kagan not to advise the
administration on the health care bill
the law clearly states that justices
must recuse themselves if they
participated as counsel advisor or
material witness concerning the
proceeding or expressed an opinion
concerning the merits of the particular
case while they worked in a government
capacity
the public has a right to know the
extent of justice Kagan's involvement
with the legislation as well as any
previously stated legal opinions about
the legislation while she served as
Solicitor General the NFL would not
allow a team to officiate its own game
if justice kagan was part of the
administration's team that put the
healthcare mandate into play she should
not officiate when it comes before the
Supreme Court if the department has
nothing to hide why not provide Congress
with the requested information the
continued refusal to cooperate with
legitimate oversight inquiries only
heightens concerns that she may in fact
have a conflict of interest President
Obama has promised an open and
transparent government unfortunately we
often see a closed and secretive Justice
Department I know all members the
committee looked forward to asking
questions on these and other issues and
I'll now recognize the gentleman from
Michigan the ranking member of the
Judiciary Committee mr. Conyers thank
you chairman Smith and a hearty welcome
to not only the Attorney General of the
United States Eric Holder but as well to
a well this is the most numerous number
of police chiefs and Department of
Justice officials that I've seen in this
room at one time in quite a while all of
them but particularly to the Detroit
Police Chief ralph Godby who is here I
send a special welcome now a chairman
Smith would it be appropriate that our
colleague a former member of the
committee Adam Schiff of California sit
on the dais with us mr. Conyers we
normally don't do that but in this case
be very pleased to have the gentleman
from California mr. Schiff sit up at the
diets with us we do we do have a policy
that non-members the committee will not
be
able to ask questions but we certainly
welcome his presence up here I thank you
for that courtesy Adam come on up if he
can find room the there are two parts to
my comments this morning members of the
committee
the first is deals with what are the
problems underlying the reason for the
hearing and the second deal more
specifically with the career and
contributions of the Attorney General of
the United States and I have the
privilege of putting these solutions
that I'd like you to consider out in my
opening statement we can go over the
details oddness IAM if you like but I'd
refer everyone to the November 8th 2011
hearings in the United States Senate
Committee on the judiciary in which
chairman Pat Leahy with more than a
dozen senators on that committee have
plowed through this and I've been going
over and over it for the last couple
days but I think I think you want to
have that as a basis for anybody that's
particularly interested now the problem
of gun trafficking in the southwest is a
serious problem and I think and I
recommend to my Judiciary Committee
colleagues with whom this whole subject
matter
is the jurisdiction of this committee
that we commit to maintaining the new
rule requiring the reporting of multiple
sales of semi-automatic weapons and
shotguns rifles by individuals in the
southwest border states there have been
a number of programs that have dealt
with this subject but I think that
that's probably number one on my
recommended list secondly we must help
we must see to it that we confirm a
director of Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms
has been operating under acting
directors for the last five and 1/2
years the Senate has failed to act on
the nominations not only of the current
president but a President Bush as well
so if we're going to criticize ATF I
think we we must work to revitalize it
not to tear it down because it's too
important a source of protection and
ending a way of ending violence in this
important part of our country and last
we must enact some legislation to
prohibit gun trafficking the multiple
the transfer of multiple guns when we
know it they will be transferred to
those who are legally prohibited from
carrying a gun or people who intend to
use guns illegally must be further
prohibited by legislative connect and
congressional action I commend
New York colleague carolyn maloney who's
sponsored a very good idea in in this
regard and so i conclude mr. chairman
and members by telling you i have never
encountered a an attorney general a more
dedicated and more professionally
effective than the current occupant of
that chair eric holder who has inch it
has achieved impressive results across
the full range of his mission especially
what has happened in the Civil Rights
Division and I think that the questions
today here are appropriate I think the
hearing is a fair I think we have a
chairman that will make sure we proceed
in a manner that will make us all proud
that we attended and participated in
this hearing today but we also know that
letting guns roam around this country is
something that all of us have a great
responsibility to make sure that that is
diminished or comes to an end as soon as
possible
and I thank you mr. chairman for this
opportunity and Thank You mr. Conyers
for those comments
the gentleman of from California
chairman of the Oversight and Government
Reform Committee is recognized for an
opening statement Thank You chairman and
I'd first like to ask unanimous consent
that the following document be placed in
the record December 7th article by
cheryl atkinson entitled documents ATF
used fast and furious to make case for
gun regulations without objection
they'll be made a part of the
Thank You mr. chairman I thank you for
holding this hearing it is deja vu all
over again we are beginning the process
of getting to the bottom to the truth of
fast and furious I take exception to my
colleague on the other side of the aisle
mr. Conyers what is too important is the
Second Amendment the idea that
regulations without any approval of
Congress have been added to create
databases in the southern southwestern
states including California Arizona
Mexico New Mexico clear Texas and New
Mexico clearly shows that in fact this
administration is more interested in
building databases more interested in
talking about gun control than actually
controlling the drugs drugs and guns
that they had control over whether its
money laundering or in fact it is the
flow of guns knowingly just one
individual was allowed to buy under the
auspices of the Justice Department 700
weapons knowing exactly who they were
going to before they ever went our
discovery with the help of Senator
Grassley has shown that this was not an
accident and that this project was
failed and flawed from the beginning it
is not just ATF it is not just DEA
in fact it includes the Department of
Homeland Security in age in a task force
that obviously did not respect the
safeguards of the American people Brian
Terry is dead today in my opinion
because of this failed program but even
today we will not hear just as taking
responsibility they will instead talk
about the two guns that were recovered
yes they were from fast and furious but
ballistics are inconclusive and yet this
Justice Department is not looking for a
third weapon they are not looking for
who killed Brian Terry well they try to
have the plausible deniability that Fast
and Furious may not have been
responsible that's reprehensible to the
family suffering under Brian Terry's
needless murder mr. chairman fast and
furious began in November 2009
it was a new operation building on a
failed operation under the previous
administration the difference in the
previous administration is there was
coordination with the Mexican government
they made a real effort under
wide-receiver to pass off a small amount
of weapons and track them this program
just the opposite even knowing the drug
cartels that were going to receive them
they simply allowed them to go to the
stash house and mr. attorney general
today I hope you will not point fingers
and say that somehow this is not organic
there is nothing more organic than law
enforcement officer being gunned down
because of a failure to protect within
the Department of Justice there is
nothing more organic in Congress's
responsibility then in fact following up
on Congress being lied to my committee
chest next door was systematically lied
to by your own representatives there is
a high likelihood the individual was
deliberately duped but he was duped by
people who still work for you today
still work for you today
the president has said he has full
confidence in this Attorney General I
have no confidence in a president who
has full confidence in an attorney
general who is in fact not terminated or
dealt with the individuals including key
lieutenants who from the very beginning
had some knowledge and long before Brian
Terry was gunned down knew enough to
stop this program there has been written
there has been an attempt to find
scapegoats many of the people have been
pointed to do share in the blame but mr.
attorney-general the blame must go to
your desk and you must today take the
real responsibility why haven't you
terminated the many people involved why
is it that we're still hearing about
inconsistencies that don't even take the
correct responsibility for Border Patrol
Agent Brian Terry's death those are the
things we want to hear today and mr.
attorney general I respect the fact that
you said in the Senate that you gave
truthful testimony but I would like to
hear what when a few days becomes a few
weeks or a few weeks becomes a few
months are we to have the confidence
that the president says he has in you
and the many people up and down the
chain of command at justice who saw this
program this operation and let it happen
and the many people who called your
legislative affairs representative who's
sitting right behind you caused him to
bring false testimony to committee it is
unheard of for testimony or for letters
or testimony to be taken back they've
had to be taken back because of people
who still work for justice mr. Chairman
I thank you for your indulgence and I
appreciate the opportunity to speak here
and would ask that Blake Farenthold a
member of my committee who has been
intimately involved in the investigation
also be allowed to sit on the dais under
the same terms as mr. Schiff committee
is he a member of Congress he is a
member of Congress mr. I said thank you
for your is a freshman from Texas he's
impacted by these gun control
regulations he is an attorney I
understand there is no room right now
but we'll consider that request in just
a minute as much as I would like to have
a Texas colleague up at the podium he
got a few but it's not what former
member of the Judiciary Committee though
we certainly appreciate his expertise on
the subject so let's wait until we have
room and we'll take it up at that point
thank the gentleman the gentleman from
Virginia mr. Scott the ranking member of
the crime subcommittee is recognized for
an opening statement Thank You mr.
chairman and I join my colleagues in
welcoming the Attorney General this
morning understand that the invitation
to the Attorney General to appear this
morning specifically referenced gun
trafficking in the southwest border so
today we have an opportunity to discuss
with them the positive steps we must
take to protect our citizens from
illegal firearms
I'm harden that this Attorney General
recognizes that the smartest and most
effective way to protect ourselves from
crime is to prevent it from occurring in
the first place with respect to
preventing firearm violence there are
steps that we can take to reduce the
toll of the injured and murdered and
there are steps that we must take in
order to enhance the ability of law
enforcement to infective to effectively
in
the gate gun crimes that have already
occurred a note as it's often said
around here that the best strategy to
use when you're in a hole is to stop
digging
unfortunately this committee approved
and the House passed a dangerous bill
that would override the laws of almost
every state by requiring each state to
accept concealed handgun carry permits a
concealed handgun carry permits from
other states even if the permit holder
would not be allowed to carry or even
possess a handgun in his home state or
the state where he is traveling actions
like this make the hole deeper and do
not make us safer we in Congress can
best take the steps to help law
enforcement prevent and investigate gun
violence specifically with reference to
the problem of gun trafficking on the
southwest border we know that the way
that the rule that window effect in
August requiring the reporting of
multiple sales of certain assault
weapons is an important tool to help law
enforcement fight the straw purchasing
that fuels gun trafficking unfortunately
while that rule was under consideration
twenty-one members of this committee
voted last February to prevent funds
from being used to implement this
important reporting requirement if that
measure had been included in the final
version the prohibition against that
reporting requirement had been included
in the final version of the bill the ATF
would not be receiving these reports
today and they would be denied
information which is helping them
investigate suspected straw purchasing
the ATF has important has an important
role in protecting us from the dangers
of illegal use and trafficking of
firearms the illegal use and storing of
explosives and acts of arson and bombing
we must make sure this is agency is
capable of fulfilling its important
mission and it needs strong leadership
in that light we need to encourage our
Senate colleagues to confirm the
president's nominee to be director of
the ATF finally when we we have learned
that we need to give prosecutors a
critical additional tool to fight gun
trafficking for example we need a
statute that specifically prohibits the
transfer
multiple firearm simple firearms into
the hands of those legally ineligible to
possess them and to those who intend to
use them to commit crimes
I hope this committee will take action
on legislation in this area in the near
future these are things we need to do to
address the real problem and fold those
who want to focus on the on Operation
Fast and Furious and gun walking tax the
tactics that it employed I would just
note that these tax tactics originated
in the ATF investigations under the Bush
administration and in November 16 2007
memo refers to the fact that so-called
gun walking was already occurring in the
Bush administration in contrast is no
evidence that Attorney General Holder
knew of this tactics while they were
being used and he should be praised for
consistently saying that they were
unacceptable and referring this matter
to the Inspector General soon after he
learned about them so I thank the
Attorney General for appearing here
today and I look forward to his
testimony I yield back thank mr. Scott
we're pleased to welcome today's witness
United States Attorney General Eric H
holder Jr on February 3rd 2009 Attorney
General Holder was sworn in as the 82nd
Attorney General of the United States
Attorney General Holder has enjoyed a
long and distinguished career in public
service first joining the department
through the Attorney General's honors
program in 1976 he became one of the
department's first attorneys to serve in
the newly formed Public Integrity
section he went on to serve as a judge
of the Superior Court of the District of
Columbia and the US Attorney for the
District of Columbia in 1997 mr. holder
was named by President Clinton to be the
Deputy Attorney General prior to
becoming Attorney General mr. holder was
a litigation partner at Covington and
Burling LLP in Washington DC mr. holder
a native of New York City is a graduate
of Columbia University and Columbia Law
School again we welcome you and look
forward to your testimony mr. chairman
mr. Chairman I would move that the
witness be sworn
I am going to ask that the gentleman
withdraw that for two reasons first of
all the Attorney General did receive a
letter from the committee reminding him
of the need and in effect that he is
testifying under oath and two we don't
need to go through that necessarily
because that is assumed by anybody who
does testify before the committee point
of inquiry mr. chairman isn't it true
that a false statement to Congress
there's a different criminal violation
than a sworn statement I believe the
answer that is yes then I would once
again ask since this committee has at
times sworn witnesses as of all the
committee's that in light of fact Jim if
the gentleman will yield
I misunderstood the question and the
answer was no so it is deemed as if he
is under oath right now any witness so
he is exactly the same as if he said
under our rules that is correct
then I withdraw okay I thank the
gentleman if the Attorney General will
proceed Thank You mr. chairman
chairman Smith ranking member Conyers
and members of the committee I
appreciate the opportunity to appear
before you today to describe the
decisive action that we have taken to
ensure that the flawed tactics used in
Operation Fast and Furious and in
earlier operations under the prior
administration are never repeated for
nearly three years I've been privileged
to work with this committee to
strengthen national security and to
strengthen law enforcement and I'm
extremely extremely proud of our record
of achievement in officers around the
world the department's 117 thousand
employees have made historic progress in
protecting the American people from a
range of unprecedented threats from
global terrorism and violent crime to
financial fraud human trafficking and
more we have disrupted numerous
potentially devastating terrorist plots
and successfully prosecuted scores of
dangerous terrorists the department's
efforts on behalf of the most vulnerable
among us including victims of civil
rights abuses and hate crimes have never
been more effective and the partners
partnerships that we have built with
state
and tribal law enforcement officials
have never been stronger today it's a
privilege to be joined by several of our
key public safety partners these five
police executives chief Fred Beale field
of Baltimore Commissioner Ed Davis of
Boston chief Rodney Monroe of Charlotte
chief Ralph Godby of Detroit and
Commissioner Charles Ramsey of
Philadelphia have been leaders in
developing and implementing innovative
and effective crime prevention
strategies they have also worked closely
with the department in advancing
critical efforts to reverse the alarming
rise in law enforcement fatalities in
recent years the work that we do along
the southwest border is influenced by
the efforts that they have undertaken in
their own cities in the cities that they
serve and in communities across the
country this work is a priority and in
our ongoing efforts to protect the
American people and our brave law
enforcement personnel a critical area of
focus will continue to be our battle
against gun violence on the southwest
border now in recent years the
department has devoted significant
resources to this fight and specifically
to addressing the unacceptable rate of
illegal firearms trafficking from the
United States to Mexico unfortunately in
the pursuit of that laudable goal
unacceptable tactics were adopted as
part of Operation Fast and Furious now
as I have repeatedly stated allowing
guns to walk whether in this
administration or the prior one is
wholly unacceptable the use of this
misguided tactic is inexcusable and it
must never happen again
soon after learning about the
allegations raised by ATF agents
involved with Fast and Furious I took
action designed to ensure accountability
February I asked the department's acting
inspector general to investigate the
matter and in early March I ordered that
a directive be sent to law enforcement
agents and prosecutors prohibiting such
tactics more recently the new acting
director of ATF todd Jones implemented
reforms to prevent these tactics from
being used in the future including
training and stricter oversight
procedures for all significant
investigations now although the
department has taken steps to ensure
such tactics are never used again it is
an unfortunate reality that we will
continue to feel the effects of this
flawed operation for years to come
guns lost during this operation will
continue to show up at crime scenes on
both sides of the border as we work to
identify where errors occurred and to
ensure that these mistakes never happen
again
we must not lose sight of the critical
challenge that this flawed operation has
highlighted and that is the battle to
stop the flow of guns to Mexico of the
nearly 94 thousand guns that have been
recovered and traced in Mexico in the
last five years more than 64,000 were
sourced to the United States during this
time the trafficking of firearms across
our southwest border has reputed to
approximately 40,000 deaths in Mexico
now the reforms that we have undertaken
do not make any of the losses of life
more bearable for grieving families
these tragedies do ever portray ver in
very stark terms the exceptionally
difficult challenges that law
enforcement agencies confront every day
and working to disrupt illegal firearms
transfers Operation Fast and Furious
appears to have been a deeply flawed
effort to respond to these very
challenges as we work to avoid future
losses and further mistakes it is
unfortunate that some have used
inflammatory and inappropriate rhetoric
about one particular tragedy that had
occurred near the southwest border in an
effort to score political points early
one nearly 1 year ago while working to
protect his fellow citizens US Customs
and Border Protection agent Brian Terry
was violently murdered in Arizona we all
should feel outraged about his death and
as I have communicated directly to agent
Terry's family we are dedicated to
pursuing justice on his behalf the
department is also working to answer
questions that the Terry family has
raised including whether and how
firearms connected to fast and furious
end up with Mexican drug cartels in her
independent review I expect the
department's acting inspector general to
answer these questions I understand that
Congress also wants answers Justice
Department employees have been working
tirelessly to identify to locate and to
provide relevant information
this committee founded the two other
committees that are investigating fast
and furious all while preserving the
integrity of our ongoing criminal
investigations and prosecutions the
department has been fully cooperative
and responsive and its dealings with
Sandra's I have answered questions in
the House and the Senate on four
occasions concerning this matters to
date we have provided almost 5,000 pages
of documents for congressional
investigators to review we have
scheduled numerous witness interviews
and testified at public hearings in just
last week we provided an unprecedented
access to internal deliberative
documents to explain how inaccurate
information was initially conveyed to
Congress these documents demonstrate the
Justice Department personnel relied on
information provided by supervisors from
the components in the best position to
know the relevant facts we now know that
some information provided by those
supervisors was inaccurate now I
understand that in subsequent interviews
with congressional investigators these
supervisors have stated that they did
not know at the time that information
provided in the letter to congressional
leaders earlier this year was inaccurate
the documents produced to date also
Balai the remarkable notion that this
operation was conceived by department
leaders as some have claimed it is my
understanding that department leaders
were not informed about the
inappropriate tactics employed in this
operation until those tactics were made
public and as is customary turn to those
with supervisory responsibilities over
the operation in an effort to learn but
what is clear is that disrupting the
dangerous flow of firearms along the
southwest border and putting an end to
the violence that has claimed far too
many limes lives is and will continue to
be a top priority for this Department of
Justice this year alone we have led
successful investigation into the
murders of the United States citizens in
Mexico created new cartel targeting
prosecutorial units and secured the
extradition of more than 100 defendants
wanted by United States law enforcement
including the former head of the Tijuana
cartel
he will also build crime-fighting
capacity on both sides of the border
developing new procedures for using
evidence gathered in Mexico to prosecute
gun traffickers in US courts by training
thousands of Mexican prosecutors and
investigators by successfully fighting
to enhancing sentencing guidelines for
convicting traffickers and straw
purchasers and by pursuing coordinated
multi district investigations of gun
trafficking rings now despite this
progress we have more to do and each of
us has a duty to act and to rise above
partisan divisions and politically
motivated gotcha games the American
people deserve better it is time for a
new dialogue about these important
issues one that is respectful
responsible and factual this will
require us to apply the lessons that
we've learned from law enforcement
officers like the ones who sit behind me
today who protect public safety and our
national security every day in that
regard not only did ATF agents bring the
inappropriate and misguided tactics of
Operation Fast and Furious to light they
also sounded the alarm for a more
effective laws to combat gun trafficking
and improve public safety ATF agents who
testify before the House Committee on
Oversight and Government Reform this
summer explained that the agency's
ability to stem the flow of guns from
the United States into Mexico suffers
from a lack of effective enforcement
tools one critical first step should be
for Congress to provide ATF with the
tools and the authorities that it needs
now unfortunately earlier this year the
majority of House members voted to keep
law enforcement in the dark when
individuals purchase multiple
semi-automatic rifles shotguns and long
guns like ak-47s in gun shops and for
Southwest border states going forward
the hope that we can work to work
together to provide law enforcement
agents with the tools that they
desperately need to protect the country
and to ensure their own safety and for
their sake we cannot afford to allow the
tragic mistakes of Operation Fast and
Furious to become a political sideshow
or a series of media opportunities
instead we must move forward and
recommit ourselves to our shared public
safety obligations I am willing to work
with you in
effort I look forward to questions Thank
You mr. Attorney General
other members are going to ask you about
fast and furious so I'm going to pick a
different subject and ask you about the
extent of justice Kagan's involvement
with the health care legislation my
first question is this to your knowledge
did then Solicitor General Kagan ever
give advice or express an opinion on
legal or constitutional issues involving
the health care legislation I do not
believe so in fact as I testified in the
Senate last month I guess we took steps
to physically exclude or conversation
what what month did that take place when
did you start excluding her from those
types of meetings I'm not sure when that
started but my memory is that whenever
we had conversations about the health
care bill then the Solicitor General
Kagan was not present and the reason for
excluding her is because of her possible
consideration for the Supreme Court yeah
I think that's right we just know she
testified that she first became aware of
that possibility that she might be
considered in early March so you would
not have excluded her prior to early
March
well I again I don't know exactly when
these events occurred but I do feel
comfortable in saying that in terms of
the conversations that occurred in my
conference room about the health care
legislation right but would you have had
any reason to exclude her any reason to
wall her off in the words that you were
told by a deputy prior to the time that
she was considered for the Supreme Court
well I can tell you that with regard to
as I said the conversations that
occurred in my conference room about the
health care bill I did not remember her
being rhenium would you be able to check
your records to find out what the date
would have been when you started telling
her that she should either excuse or
recuse herself from those discussions I
will attempt to do that I'm not sure
that that information exists anyplace
but to the extent that it does I'll
provide it with to you okay and would
you have a record of any meetings
because of your schedule that she
attended would I have a record right of
any meetings that she attended because
if you went back
I could look at your schedule I assume
that that would be on your schedule yeah
they schedule for what is our 9:15
meeting list the people who are expected
to arrive expected to be there I don't
know we put actually keep trying
actually but okay if you'll give me the
days when you started telling her that
again I don't believe you would have any
reason to exclude her before she was
being considered for the Supreme Court
vacancy and as I mentioned in my opening
statement she would actually have a duty
to be involved in conversations
regarding the health care bill let me go
to another question this goes to some of
the correspondents that I've written you
asking for documents and to be allowed
to interview both present and former
staff members but is the department
asserting a legal privilege in refusing
to comply with my request for those
documents and those interviews about
then Solicitor General Kagan s
involvement with the health care
legislation you know your letter to me
did not assert any legal privilege yeah
the department has released documents
under FOIA relating to this matter and
those documents are certainly available
to members of the committee the
documents that we have released are
consistent with I'm not asking about the
documents are you asserting a legal
privilege is that why you are refusing
to give me those documents well it is
our view that in terms of trying to
determine the answers to the questions
that you have that with regard to
recusal questions those are questions
best brought by those who involved in
the context of the litigation and so you
are not asserting any legal privilege
well there are it seems to me separation
of powers concerns given the fact that
members of Congress are amici amicus's a
McKee and in the ongoing legislation and
so I would have concerns there with
regard to separation okay what's what
would be the legal privilege you're
asserting if you assert one then well
all I'm saying is that with regard to
the information that is requested it has
been okay so again you're not asserting
a legal privilege is there any reason
therefore I should not get the documents
or be able to interview the individuals
that I requested to interview well as I
have said that the federal law provides
for the resolution of these recusal
questions and each justice has to make
those kinds of right I'm not talking
about recusal questions or what
Court justice minor might I do I'm
talking about my request for documents I
can't imagine any good reason why you
would withhold them unless you were to
assert a legal privilege and then we
could discuss a legal privilege but I
haven't heard you say you are asserting
any legal privilege well the documents I
think that you have requests have
essentially been released under a FOIA
that has been filed and those documents
are available no the documents that I
requested may or may not have been
released that's what we're trying to
find out is what other documents might
exist we've also requested to interview
two individuals and you have not agreed
to let us interview those individuals
but if you're not asserting a legal
privilege then I'll move forward with
scheduling those interviews and look
forward to the documents well we've not
expressed I guess at this point a legal
privilege we have expressed as I
indicated before constitutional concerns
about the nature yeah I know but
concerns don't rise the level of a legal
privilege if we all have concerns about
a lot of subjects I've expressed some of
my concerns today but if you're not
going to assert a legal privilege then I
don't see any reason why I shouldn't get
those documents and conduct those
interviews thank you for that the
gentleman from Michigan mr. Conyers is
recognized for those questions Matt
Thank You mr. chairman
you've got here chief Ralph God be lots
of other police chiefs and law
enforcement people behind you would you
tell us how you partner with them to
fight violent crime and particularly gun
running with state and local police
officers who are on the front line sir
well the gentleman who sit behind me and
the people who they represent our
essential partners in our fight against
violent crime generally and against gun
violence in particular the federal
government relies on our state and local
partners who are obviously in the front
lines in this fight we try to support
them in ways that we can we try to come
up with programs that protect their
lives but the reality is that in coming
up with and that's why I think these
five gentlemen are so good to have here
today they are
we've come up with really innovative
programs that we have tried to support
and then try to expand across the nation
they are first and foremost great
partners in this fight and what they are
doing in their cities are things that
we're trying to replicate not only in
other cities but in the work that we're
doing along the southwest border as well
thank you Oh tell me where is the
Mexican government in all of this gun
running and violence and drug epidemics
that that goes on but that usually
starts in Mexico but eventually gets to
the US in the southwest area what's
what's the Mexican government's role and
attitude how do you work with them they
have also been good partners president
Calderon has I think very courageously
committed his government to fight the
cartels he has done so in a way that has
done I think at great you know political
cost it has certainly cost the lives of
many Mexican law enforcement officials
who have been a part of this battle
40,000 people in Mexico have lost their
lives over the course of the last five
years in connection with this with this
fight the Mexican government is
committed to eradicating the cartels we
have worked with them in unprecedented
ways in terms of extraditing people to
the United States in cooperation and
sharing intelligence and working with
vetted units in Mexico we have moved
resources to the southwest border and
have linked up with in task forces with
our Mexican partners so our interaction
with the Mexican government in dealing
with these cartels is really
unprecedented well
I mentioned several things that we
really ought to do in terms of getting
on top of not just the drug the gun
smuggling and gun working but the drug
problem as well and you're our chief law
enforcement officer in the nation I know
you're relying on state and local law
enforcement as well but what are the
what are the big issues what's the big
picture in terms of what it is we might
want to consider in the Congress oh god
to help get on top of this and to help
you and the Department of Justice get on
top of not only the drugs but the guns
as well well I think there are certain
things that would be very helpful there
is no gun trafficking statute now or
even an express prohibition on straw
purchasing if Congress would consider
legislation in that regard I think that
would be that would be good we have to
rely now on paperwork violations to try
to get at gun traffickers and the
sentences that are typically given for
those kinds of technical violations are
far too low for the serious nature of
the crimes it is far too easy for
criminals to get their hands on weapons
congressional support for the regulation
that we put in place along those in
those four border states to deal with
the long guns the long guns that can be
purchased there a regulation that is
consistent with what we already do with
regard to handguns is something that
congressional support would be would be
important for so the possibility of
having ways in which we could have a
good dialogue about effective measures
that would reduce the flow of guns to
Mexico make this nation more safe
protect the lives of people
in law enforcement in this country and
respect the Second Amendment at the same
time is something that I think a
meaningful good dialogue with members of
Congress would be very productive well
I'm glad you mentioned the Second
Amendment so that my friend and
colleague darrell Issa won't be nervous
about the other strategies that you'll
be using I'll still be nervous I thank
you very much
General Holder and I return the balance
of my time
thank you Thank You mr. Conyers the
gentleman from Wisconsin mr.
Sensenbrenner recognized for his
questions okay thank you very much mr.
chairman mr. holder I deeply appreciate
your coming here to talk largely about
fast and furious and the way this has
been handled within the Justice
Department I think has put the Justice
Department as an institution under a
cloud that has not been exceeded since
the infamous COINTELPRO scandal of the
1970s and here at the top of the Justice
Department do you think the buck stops
with you I'm ultimately responsible for
all of the actions that occur within the
department but I think as you look at
what happened with regard to fast and
furious and try to decide what kind of
performance I have done in this regard
then you have to look at what happened
well what I did once I learned of these
matters well that's that's a you know a
question of when you learned it because
there have been inconsistent submissions
to Congress you know you yourself
testified that you'd only heard about it
a few weeks earlier and then in November
you said it probably was a few months as
late as October 7th in response the
allegations that you lied on May 3rd you
wrote to Congress your statements on
fast and furious have been quote
truthful and consistent men your
underlings on February 4th assistant
Ronald White's responded to senator
grassley denying that the ATF had walked
guns and that letter ended up being
withdrawn you know as mr. Issa has said
lying to Congress is a federal felony
you know I don't want to say that you
have committed a felony mr. attorney
general but obviously there have been
statements so misleading that a letter
had to be withdrawn I think that some
head should roll and I do agree with
Senator Grassley that assistant attorney
general for the criminal division Lanny
Breuer should be fired and I know that
that decision is not yours but it is the
president's but I think that merely
getting the head of the ATF director at
the time is not sufficient since it's
obvious that there was knowledge within
the Justice Department what are you
going to do to clean up this mess well
first let me make something very clear
and in response to an assertion that you
made or hinted at nobody in the Justice
Department has lied no but I was the
letter withdrawn the letter was
withdrawn because there's information in
there that was inaccurate the Justice
Department letter of February okay well
tell me what's the difference between
lying and misleading Congress in this
context well if you want to have this
legal or conversation it all has to do
with your state of mind and whether or
not you had the requisite intent to come
up with something that can be considered
perjury or a lie the information that
was provided in that February 4th letter
was gleaned by the people who drafted a
letter after they interacted with people
who they thought were in the best
position to have the information now now
the way the wagons down the street are
in a pretty tight circle you know mr.
Attorney General the American people
need the truth they haven't gotten the
truth from what has been coming out of
the Justice Department in the last year
and they were relying on Congress to get
the truth now you're here today and
again I appreciate your being here today
as
a way to get the truth but the answers
that you have given so far are basically
saying well gee somebody else did it and
you know there there is really no
responsibility within the Justice
Department you know the thing is is that
if we don't get to the bottom of this
and that requires your assistance on
that there is only one alternative that
Congress has and it's called impeachment
where our subpoena powers are plenary
and there can't be any type of a legal
immunity or privilege that can be
asserted on that now you know I've done
more impeachments than anybody else in
the history of the country it is an
expensive and messy affair and I don't
want to go this far but if we keep on
getting pushed down the road and the can
keeps on getting kicked and we don't get
closer to this what is Congress to do so
that we don't spend all of our time in
court arguing privilege which is not a
way to get at the truth well the Justice
Department has released facts and I
think that's what we need to focus on
that part of the creation of the
February 4th letter I made the
determination that we would release
things that a Justice Department has
never ever released before deliberative
core deliberative material about how
that letter was put together information
that clearly could have been withheld
and it has always been withheld by my
predecessors and I expect by my
successors as well getting to the bottom
of this is something that we all want to
do the Inspector General pursuant to my
request is conducting an investigation
of this matter and I suspect we'll have
a great many more answers than we
presently do I don't have the ability to
do a top-to-bottom investigation at this
point out of deference to the
investigation that is being done by the
Inspector General that does not
however preclude me from taking action
that I think appropriate based on
information that comes to my attention
in spite of the fact that the Inspector
General has an ongoing investigation
well you won't have an independent
counsel and we end up having the Justice
Department investigating itself in the
absence of an independent counsel and
you know having gone through
interminable hearings on COINTELPRO with
all due respect mr. Attorney General
you've got to get this done much more
quickly than plugging the holes that
Cowan tell Pro ended up showing existed
in the department that time and I yield
back chairman I have a parliamentary
inquiry Thank You mr. Sensenbrenner for
what reason does the gentlewoman from
Texas seek clarification the gentleman
in his questioning indicated impeachment
I was not sure which official which
person he was speaking of in terms of
the gentleman from Wisconsin was
referring to the fact that while he was
chairman of this committee he oversaw
the impeachment process it's German
we're on work its opponent continued my
a my inquiry the state gentleman the
only one alternative is impeachment I'm
trying to do that it's not a pulmonary
inquiry the gentleman from California
mr. Berman is recognized Thank You mr.
chairman and Larry vacation thank mr.
Thank You mr. chairman I would like to
yield a little time to the ranking
member on this issue Thank You Howard
Berman
I merely wanted to clear the record with
a Jim Sensenbrenner I've had far more
impeachment experience than he has ah
well the gentleman yield
yeah the answer is is is only if the
chairman allows my time to be extended
beejamin from California is recognized
for a four or five minutes that's
correct
all right then
Thank You mr. chairman
we've heard a lot some of it quite
unbelievably overblown
I'd like to give you some of the truth
as I see it you are on record as
admitting that The Fast & Furious
program was a fundamentally flawed
program Fast and Furious is only one
program in many undertaken by the US law
enforcement authorities not only to
limit the harm of illegal gun
trafficking but also most important to
chief the broader goal of protecting US
and Mexican citizens there got to be a
little perspective on what's going on in
the us-mexico relationship on this issue
once President Calderon made the
historic decision to take the fight
directly to the drug cartels law
enforcement both in Mexico and the
United States became more complicated
and more dangerous and the fact is and I
see it from a Foreign Affairs Committee
perspective as well as from this
perspective that us-mexico law
enforcement cooperation and general
cooperation is wider and deeper today
than it has ever been in the history of
our two nations the Department of
Justice has apprehended and extradited
an unprecedent number of criminals
including some of the most dangerous
cartel leaders they have successfully
investigated violent crimes committed
against American nationals in Mexico and
along the border they have trained
hundreds of Mexican prosecutors and
police officers many of whom work side
by side with US counterparts on these
shared goals the level of intelligence
sharing and cooperation is unprecedented
at this particular time we also have to
acknowledge the negative impact caused
by the significant stream of guns going
into Mexico from the United States every
day thousands of guns are smuggled
across the United States border into
Mexico making citizens of Mexico and the
United States less safe the u.s. south
where border states south west border
states Texas New Mexico Arizona and Cal
vanya are the top four source locations
for firearms received and traced in
Mexico back to the United States general
holder I'm wondering if you could
develop you I think you got into this a
little bit with ranking member Conyers
what could the Congress be doing in
terms of funding in terms of passing
laws to help make this a successful
endeavor I would like you to just expand
on some of those specific issues are we
giving you the resources you need to
make this cooperation produce the goal
that both countries governments share
well frankly no we have sought
additional legislative enhancements to
our abilities to deal with the gun
trafficking problem as I indicated to
the ranking member
we've also sought funds to increase the
number of ATF agents who operate in
these teams along the southwest border I
think we requested funds so that we have
14 of these teams that number was
reduced based on the funding level that
we got to about seven or eight I believe
which decreased our ability to act or
interact effectively or as effectively
as we might with our Mexican
counterparts so there are funding issues
there are issues with regard to the
confirmation of an ATF director a
permanent ATF director there are
legislative statutory tools that we
could use from Congress and that we have
proposed all of these things would help
us in our fight against the gun
trafficking problem that you have I
think so rightfully identified the only
thing I guess I would just close with
the simple statement that as we pursue
responsibly our oversight
responsibilities on a program that you
have stated was fundamentally flawed
that we keep in mind our obligations as
a Congress to help something that I
think there is a broad consensus must
continue must expand and must achieve
the goals that our two governments are
committed to and to
have some perspective on what's going on
that perspective seems to have been lost
in some of the rhetoric that is come in
recently with the gentleman io IL with
the gentleman yield do I have time to
you do the German has five seconds left
yeah I yield I would I would just make
the point that it's that fast and
furious is not a program we've been
repeatedly told it's less than a program
it's just an operation just an operation
and generally is recognized for an
additional 30 seconds I take your point
I just don't quite understand it well
just that that as the general when we
try to adjust the gentleman from
California has the time with the
gentleman continue to yield I thank the
gentleman the the point that I'm making
is is that there is a wide question of a
lot of things that go on to justice and
I agree with the gentleman that we need
to look at the overall management of
justice but this small operation and the
refusal to give us the truth early on
has caused it to be a [ __ ]
I appreciate the time I also would love
to hear about Congress's agenda to make
this cooperation truly as effective as
it could be funding the legislation
regarding the the paper trail on guns
and and all the other things that the
general mentioned that we should be
doing Thank You mr. Berman the Judiciary
Committee will stand in recess until
immediately after the series of four
votes I do not expect to take a lunch
break so when we return we will proceed
until the next series of votes about 115
we stand in recess until after these
votes
what about my flight time we switched
you for
you